whom uh who needs at least uh in the
algorithms Community uh no introduction
uh Andrew Goldberg um has done uh very
important work in algorithms and
algorithm implementation uh for many
years starting uh with Max flow and Min
cost flow uh then in in work with his
colleagues at Microsoft uh research on
uh on routing um in in Road networks and
uh on and on he's uh he's uh helped
guide us in what makes uh an algorithm
implementable and practical so I'm uh
pleased to see he's going to be speaking
to exactly that topic
today okay so I'm going to talk about
challenges in research on practical
algorithms and both industrial
challenges and academic challenges and I
conclude with some uh ideas for
collaboration between industry
and so
uh so the views I present Are My Views
uh and they're mostly in the context of
practical algorithms but many of the
points I make apply to other research
areas and for algorithms it's uh if
you're in Industry have an algorithm
that works is it all you need and the
answer is no because you also want to
know why it works because if something
changes like um your business scales or
you introduce a new feature you may
suddenly be in a situation where the
algorith no longer works if you don't
understand why it works and you want to
be ready for that um so basic Industrial
Research in general and an algorithms in
particular is disappearing which I think
is a bad bad for science in general and
uh so algorithms research now uh in
industry has to be done in production
environment which is uh an interesting
change and I want to sort of mention old
joke
so relationship between theory and
practice is Theory when you know
everything but nothing works in practice
and practice is when everything works
but you don't know why and when you
combine theory and practice you get that
nothing works and you don't know
why so we want to combine the and
practice in
a okay so uh academic research Pro
problems one is oversimplified
models and many real life uh
requirements are proprietary or complex
and academic research focuses on simple
clean models uh and then it's a question
of how well the simple models relate to
real life and you know it's you still
still can learn a lot from simple models
but uh there is a huge gap between uh
sort of clean problem Solutions and Real
Life
Solutions uh so an example is uh in
navigation systems turn costs so we know
that if you make a turn you have to slow
down and if if it's a right turn it's uh
usually faster than the left turn and if
uh the intersection is busy it takes
longer than if the is empty and so on so
this is something which was ignored uh
by algorithm researchers because
basically believe is oh yeah we will
introduce the St costs and all
algorithms will be affected in a similar
way and um we were somewhat surprised
that on real data we observe that in
fact if you introduce the turn costs the
uh algorithms are affected in a
different way and at that time time uh
we working we were working at Microsoft
so we had real data but we couldn't
share this data but the nice thing was
that uh we did a little bit of
experimentation and we showed that
adding a 100 second U-turn uh penalties
to uh public data allowed us to
reproduce this phenomena okay so we
actually could share it with uh academic
community so that uh they can study it
and you can see that in fact uh the
difference is Big so this was our new
algorithm which we're introducing
customizable route planning and it the
competition was contraction hierarchies
and uh the relevant metric here is time
metric because as far as distance goes
uh turns don't add to distance but for
time there's time cost and here is no
turns so turn all turn costs are zero
and these are different representations
of turn costs and you can see our
algorithm which was designed from ground
up to handle turn uh costs it wasn't
really much affected At All by
introducing of turn costs and
contraction
hierarch algorithm was affected and Cy
sorry not cury pre-processing time
increased by more than an order of
magnitude and so did preprocessing space
and for C is if you uh use the big graph
representation it uh the time went up by
less than a factor of to of two but uh
in for a compact representation it went
up by almost an order of magnitude so
it's a huge differ difference for this
algorithm and it's a relatively simple
thing right you would assume it doesn't
make a difference but it
may okay and uh so I was working for a
while on uh vehicle routing and these
are government EU regulations for uh
truck drivers and if you are designing a
practical vehicle routing algorithm you
have to take uh this into account
because otherwise your drivers will be
find all the time and you know and they
make sense from safety reasons so like
daily driving period shall not exceed 9
hours with an exception of twice a week
when it can be extended to 10 hours and
are more regulations like that and if
you think this is all uh there's another
page uh and if you think this is all uh
by the way this there's a web page where
you can read all of this uh I just want
to make point that it's complex and if
you think it's complex and not complex
enough there are also cabotage
regulations which are also as complete
and you know we all tend to think that
the U is a happy free trade family but
in fact uh at least as far as truck
drivers go countries want to protect
their own drivers so they put
restrictions on how much a foreign
driver can work in a different country
which leads to this kind of regulations
maybe even
longer and so this has algorithmic
implications so of course academic
studies ignore most of these
constraints uh
and it's already I mean vehicle routing
is already a very very hard problem so
even without all of this constraints
there is a lot to do and uh certainly
academic research generated lots of
interesting ideas but it's very hard to
say without actually reimplementing
everything of how this will work in
practice and what works better so uh
let's consider a common algorithmic
approach which is column generation uh
using constraint short SP to build
routes and if you don't know what it is
don't worry I just want to make a high
level Point uh so constraint sh the pass
algorithm sort of grows a partial pass
and it has a state associated with it
which basically captures uh the usage of
resources by this pass so for a driver
it would be how much driving time you
consumed when your last rest period was
which countries you visited when and so
on and uh the point is that uh the
algorithm the problem complexity depends
at least complexity of algorithms which
use this approach depends on the size of
the state and in theory I suspect the
dependence is exponential what it is in
practice uh it really depends but it
really strongly depends on the state
size and the more constraints you add
the bigger the exponent becomes so it's
something that really affects
performance okay so another thing is
public Benchmark quality and uh
Benchmark qualities are really uh vary
and it really depends on how careful
people in the area who are in creating
benchmarks so something like uh you know
linear algebra or travel and salesman
has really really good benchmarks in
some other areas benchmarks are ify but
they evolve so one example is maximum
weighted independent set benchmarks so
the original one which is still heavily
used comes from the second Dix challenge
which was on hard problems but uh Max
independent set was not the main focus
so they basically what they did was they
had some click problems so they took
complements of Click graphs to get
maximum independent set problems and
then they did uh node ID modul con
weights and of course this is these are
not realistic weights and even if the
original graphs came from real
applications uh which uh they had many
synthetic instances if you take a
complement of this graph it is an iffy
graph and in particular most uh real
world graphs are sparse these graphs are
dense uh and they have funny structure
and so on so this is not uh really a
good Benchmark but still heavily used
there were there are other benchmarks
for example uh those from map label
applications they're better they come
from real application but what we
discovered was that we had a vehicle
routing problem with uh which generated
some uh maximum weight independent set
sub problems and vehicle routing is
great because uh it's a multi-billion
dollar industry so if you save a quarter
percent it really matters uh so you
really really want to solve big uh
problems you get from this application
as close to Optimal as you can and what
we discovered is that these problems
have different structure different size
and different relative algorithm
performance and we actually published a
paper on uh solving this kind of
problems and also we published the data
set which was not easy uh but we have it
so in case you're interested in uh big
real life uh Max independent set
problems you can download
them okay so the point is
that uh it's still very hard to get real
data if you are in
Academia okay so Industrial Research um
basic Industrial Research is in a bad
shape and it's sort of a shame I think
for science and computer science in
general uh some highlights of Industrial
Research is there Alto was essentially a
PC with a graphics user interface which
was a decade at least ahead of its time
and another example is alav Vista which
was arguably the first really successful
search engine which uh sort of
disappeared and there are high level
problems I mean you can put fault on
everybody of why uh industrial res basic
research is
disappearing I mean it's certainly
inability to monetize high level
management an ability to see the value
of research researchers and research
managers not always doing something
which company would be interested in or
not being able to explain why it's good
and so on uh but it's it's a fact that
unfortunately uh there are very few uh
places where uh industrial places where
people can do full-time basic
research and uh in algorithms most
researchers have very limited time to do
basic research and it's unfortunate
because research is actually a full-time
job okay but something which is very
specific to
algorithms is commodity software
Engineers so um you know when I was a
PhD student most programmers had uh
Advanced degrees in math and pH physics
and computer science so they could
really learn complicated things and also
as far as data structures go uh there
were many fewer things to learn than
there's now right because computer
science develops very fast there are new
algorithms data structures you know new
learning models uh new systems uh things
which uh are being discovered so there's
much more to learn and you get sort of a
random uh uh undergraduate from a random
University which probably would be
somewhere in India uh and you cannot
expect them quickly learn uh really
sophisticated
algorithm and uh
also
uh but you sort of need softw Engineers
to take over and maintain uh production
code and work with it and also education
now since there's limited time is uh for
software Engineers it's uh based on
specific programming languages and uh
software development environment and
this is okay because vast majority of
cord is like UI or data interface or
something where uh it's it's relatively
easy right for user interface okay
there's a red button here and a blue
button here and if you click on it this
is what happens and so on it's you don't
really need a PhD in computer science to
understand this uh and also you
substitute language features for
detailed knowledge for example in Java
you can use parallel stream and not know
anything about logs or concurrency or
race conditions uh and for most cases
this is fine but if you want to uh
Implement a sophisticated really highly
tuned parallel algorithm you probably
may want to go Deer uh but then you have
to have a lot of knowledge about uh
concurrent
systems okay and there is an example
which uh was I think I saw the invited
talk by arjin lenra which is sort of
shows that a little knowledge is a
dangerous thing and we all know that an
RSA key is a product of two large primes
and so what you do is uh and also we
know that primality testing is
uh efficient so what you do is you start
with a random number and you keep imp
incrementing it by one until you get a
prime number this is your first prime
number and then you do it again you take
a random number keep implementing it
until we hit a prime number then you
multiply these two numbers and you get a
number which is hard to factor and of
course uh this is a at least L claimed
that this is a real life example so some
programmer decided that why would you
call uh a random number generator again
you just take this uh first number and
you add keep adding one to it until you
hit another prime number and can anybody
see what's wrong with
this it's a timing attack sorry a timing
attack you can tell the difference
between F2 and F1 by see how long it
runs no no I mean this is you use this
is to generate the key so it will run in
a different environment yes take the
square root exactly taking square root
is easy so you can factor a number get
this way really really easy but uh you
know if all you know is that you have
you need to take two big uh prime
numbers and multiply them you wouldn't
know that this is a bad thing so a
little knowledge is dangerous you really
to work with sophisticated algorithms
you often really need to understand what
goes on sort of much deeper than at a
very high
level okay uh and actually I have a
whole talk on what happens
when uh software Engineers take an
efficient prototype uh cord and
productize
it it's a whole different
story okay and also project managers
there are lots of managers with no
Science
Education and it's sort of one siiz
fitall metad ology because most projects
are Implement data pipeline or user
interface or something and so you know
today you're doing a red button and
tomorrow someone else will do a blue
button and
so software Engineers are treated as
fible but when you go to algorithms
there's a steep learning curve even to
understand an algorithm on High level it
takes time and to understand deeper it
takes time and also uh certain uh
background and so because of that there
are issues introduced during technology
transfer feature addition and
maintenance and also in uh often it's
not like you implemented something
transferred it uh to production and
forgot about it because often what
happens is you're in a business which is
uh evolving and growing so problem size
is growing
uh features are added and so on and you
need incremental changes to production
code and uh unfortunately scientists
have to really supervise this process at
low level to avoid problems and you sort
of need to do uh work with production
code do code reviews and so on which is
in a sense uh um Winner's curse you have
some great system transfer to production
but then you you're stuck forever with
uh uh basically helping to maintain it
and make sure that it doesn't get
screwed up because otherwise it's very
likely we'll get screwed
up okay and let me finish with uh some
uh fairly obvious points on industry
Academia collaboration so uh what is
something which unfortunately not every
company understands is there is Big
Value in industry in uh collaborating
with uh Academia and the most important
one you uh can leverage academic
research potential there are lots of
people in Academia who want to solve
real problems who have time to do basic
research and they would be happy if uh
they know what real problems are and
also uh this way you'll get
uh graduating students who are better
prepared for
industry and the way to contribute is
industry can contribute real life data
and uh publish results and do
presentations about results and also can
hire interns or have faculty spend sub
articles there but these two are
actually in some companies are very hard
because basically management doesn't see
this value proposition so nobody wants
to take risk I mean if we release this
data I don't see what good will come out
of it but maybe I'll get fired because
there's some privacy leak or something
so this is seems like an obvious
no-brainer and some companies are really
good about this this but many companies
are not so in terms of Academia the
benefits are more research
potential and also potential for
research to do real life implications
and what I mean by that many of you are
probably familiar with work on John
kleinberg which he did on Facebook data
and he really got some interesting
results about Facebook users which I
think got right up in New York Times or
some other major news uh Outlet so uh
and also
you get students which are better
prepared for uh industrial career and
not all students stay in Academia
you uh and the way to contribute is I
think algorithm scientists should have
strong software engineering skills they
should be able to work uh with real code
if they go to
Industry also it's
uh in many areas it's uh
good data sets are missing and also
the good data sets are not evaluated and
sufficiently recognized I think by the
community which sort of if you in
industry and try to release a data set
and you're in a company where it's hard
you may decide that it's not worth it so
somehow recognizing it better I think
it's cool and also I think uh standing
doing startups or spending sub articles
in industry is a way good way to learn
uh about real life live so this is all I
wanted to
say time for one
question there is
[Music]
one yes um do funders ever require
release of real data sets sorry in the
bio world the NIH requires release of
data and a lot of you know
circumstances um or at least you know
budgets money to for public databases
does that happen in the algorithms world
not really and also uh sometimes it's
hard because when I was at Microsoft and
we worked with Facebook data actually
there of an agreement that if Facebook
asks for it in 24 hours will remove all
traces of this data uh which makes it
very very hard
so I mean it would be nice but uh it uh
more many companies just will not do it
and and also if you know about privacy
it may be legitimate because there's
some user data there may be some
proprietary information in the data so I
don't think it's feasible but when it's
feasible it's very very desirable what
do you have anything to say I remember
the Netflix challenge where you were
supposed to fill in you know the
movie missing movie uh
ratings and you know that sparked a a
really really great algorithms research
soou they did got oh Netflix did so it's
not a good I don't know the rest of the
story then no no but I have to say that
in our research on uh routing algorithm
like navigation algorithms there was a
German company which released data uh
which was very very helpful and also
uh so there were some other public data
sets real data sets which I think was
one of the reasons why this research was
so successful and why now your phone can
computer out in the fraction of a
second all right we have to I just have
a com ml Commons public data sets that
you can people can download yeah it
really varies from area to area but it's
in in general it's a challenge because
uh because of uh proprietary and
information concerns and these are valid
concerns but still it shouldn't prevent
data to be made public when
possible okay let's thank Andrew
Goldberg once
more